so for the final talk of this session
where the a coffee break himself and
from Yale and he's going to tell us
about tap free energy I don't actually
know what that is the national airline
of Portugal I guess right and some other
things so take it away great ok good
afternoon everyone thank you for coming
thank you to the organizers for
organizing this wonderful workshop so
it's my first time at Simon's and when I
was watching videos of what happens at
Simon's to prepare for this talk every
video I saw was black bore lectures and
so I thought everyone gave blackboard
talks so it was too late for me to
change at this so I'm gonna give a
blackboard talk I'm gonna talk about
variational Bayesian inference in higher
dimensions this is joint work with Andre
Amnon tonari and so may both of whom are
here in the audience today okay so we're
gonna talk about Bayesian inference I'll
consider a very simple Bayesian model
which is the following we're going to
observe an m-by-n symmetric data matrix
I'll call that Y so Y is in R by M by n
and symmetric and the model for Y is
that it's going to be the sum of a Rank
1 signal component are called that
lambda over N times X X transpose and
then plus some additive Gaussian noise W
all right so here X is a signal vector
it's an RN and we're gonna do Bayesian
inference so we'll put a prior on X the
prior that we'll put is that let's say
the signal vector belongs to the
hypercube so every entry of X is plus
minus 1 and we'll just consider a
uniform prior so each entry is with
probability 1/2 equal to plus 1 and
we're probably happy with a minus 1 this
matrix W here is our noise this is
symmetric noise wouldn't consider and so
as a simple model for the noise we'll
assume it's Gaussian so above the
diagonal W IJ for I bigger than J we'll
assume let's say it's normal with mean
zero and the scaling that I'll use is
variance 1 over N below the diagonal is
just a symmetric reflection of what's
above the diagonal to make a symmetric
and then on the diagonal it doesn't
really matter what I put here because
there's no signal on the diagonal but
for certain reasons of convenience we
can consider WI I
to be normal a zero to over n let's see
and these are independent and an
observation that we can make regarding
the normalization I'm using in this
model as the following can you guys see
if I write down here so the
normalization in this model if I look at
what is the spectral norm of this Rank 1
signal it's lambda over and xx transpose
XS squared Euclidean length n so the
spectral norm of the signal component
here is lambda for this noise matrix
that I've constructed the spectral norm
of W is approximately 2 with high
probability and so you can think about
lambda here as representing a
signal-to-noise parameter and so what we
all assume throughout this talk for
lambda is that so we're gonna consider
asymptotics lambda is going to be a
constant as n goes to infinity but we'll
need to assume it's sufficiently large
is so sufficiently large and what I mean
by that is that it's larger than some
universal constant lambda not okay okay
and so I want to talk about Bayesian
inference in this model we have a prior
on next it doesn't really matter I can
set it to be 0 the rationale for 2 is
that this is then a Gaussian orthogonal
ensemble that's rotational invariant for
certain formulas involving the
likelihood it'll be convenient
okay so I want to do Bayesian inference
in this model and what that means is the
following so I want to be able to
understand what is the posterior
distribution of my signal vector X given
this observed data matrix Y and for
example a common task is that I want to
for instance compute to the expectation
of some simple function of X let's say
condition one of my observations Y all
right so let me make this actually even
more concrete let's consider a very
specific estimation problem so suppose
that I want to estimate this Rank 1
signo matrix and I'll call that video so
big ax will be little X little X
transpose so my goal is to estimate this
and let me write down the loss so the
risk function I want to consider let's
say is the expectation of the Frobenius
norm error squared so X hat is my
estimator minus the truth squared for
Venus norm difference I don't normally
this by 1 over
okay let me consider this as my
inferential tasks and so if this is what
I want to do then by standard classical
Bayesian decision theory I know what my
optimal estimate should be the optimal
estimator should be given by the Bayes
estimate so X have Bayes I'll call this
it's just a posterior mean the
expectation of XX transpose given Y so
this optimal estimator has been studied
before and in particular in a paper by
Deshpande bayamón tonari 2016 and what's
known about this estimator is the
following if i look at the actual Bayes
risk that's achieved by this estimator
so the expectation of 1 over N squared
times this for B Gnaeus norm error
squared so this is the true base this
expectation is over both this prior on X
as well as my estimator right so this
Bayes risk asymptotically as n goes to
infinity converges to a certain constant
depending on the signal-to-noise lambda
and I'll call this constants I of lambda
okay so what's known is that there are
two regimes if lambda the
signal-to-noise is less than or equal to
one then I can't do any sort of
instructing form of estimation this is I
of lambda will just be equal to one and
this is the error that you would get if
you were to just estimate zero this is a
tribute for any signal-to-noise lambda
bigger than one you can do some form of
a non-trivial estimation and this is I
lambda will be strictly between 0 and 1
so it can achieve some some correlation
with the truth
hi so this is fine so my goal is be
eight to be able to compute you know
posterior expectations of quantities
such as this and of course the
difficulty in Bayesian inference is that
exact computation of these kinds of
posteriors are believed to be
intractable right if I were to do a
naive computation with posterior I would
need to for example sum over two to ten
points on the vertices of my hyper cube
to computation so what I'm going to talk
about today is is what's known as the
variational approach to Bayesian
inference so variational these are very
students to describe to you what this is
let me call the true posterior so let me
denote that by PI of X given Y this is
the true posterior that I'm interested
in and let me call script P the class of
an approximating class of probability
distribution script P will be the class
of all product measures on the queue so
all product distributions on plus 1
minus 1 to the N what this just means is
that every single coordinate each of my
end coordinates is an independent
Bernoulli variable plus mu plus 1 minus
ok
and so corresponding to this flat class
script P so if I take any probability
distribution P and P because all the
coordinates are independent I can
parameterize this distribution by just
what is the mean of each coordinate in
other words if I were to sample a vector
X from Pete what does its mean the
expectation of X so let me call this a
vector M M sits inside the solid cube in
dimensions and the the variation
approach to inference so the most
commonly used method of variation of
inferences what's often comes called
mean filled variational inference and in
the mean field approach what we want to
do is to we want to find the
distribution T in this class of product
measures which minimizes the KL
divergence from key to the true
posterior PI of X given Y
now if I were to write out what is this
KL divergence in the particular model I
wrote down we can write that in terms of
this mean parameter here and what this
becomes as we want to find M hat which
is the minimum over the solid cube of
the following functional or call this
the mean field free energy and this
functional takes the form minus lambda
over 2n M transpose ym this is sort of
the energy term and then minus an
entropy term 1 over N sum I equals 1 to
n H of M I H here is the binary entropy
function so H of n is minus 1 plus M
over 2 log 1 plus M over 2 minus 1 minus
M over 2 log 1 minus M over 2 is just
the entropy of a Bernoulli random
variable plus 1 minus 1 would mean that
okay and so the mean field approaches I
want to find this distribution P or
equivalently this this parameter vector
M that that minimizes the subject and
it's okay so if M hat minimizes a
subjective then it has to satisfy the
first-order stationarity condition which
is that the gradient of this mean field
free energy at M has to be equal to zero
and if I differentiate this and compute
this gradient this I can rearrange as
the equation M equals the hyperbolic
tangent of lambda times y
okay so as a sort of consequence of our
main results the first theorem I want to
state is the following so what we show
is that actually this kind of
approximation is not correct as and
politically as n goes to infinity for
this model and let me be more precise so
what I mean by this is the following let
M hat be any critical point so so the
any points satisfying to serve this
first-order condition so satisfies that
the gradient of the mean field free
energy at M hat is actually equal to
zero
let me construct from M hat and estimate
of my rank one signal so that X hat the
M hat M hat transpose because the
coordinates are independent under my
posterior approximation this is also
equal to the expectation under this p
hat of XX transpose
ignoring some details on the diagonal
which are not important for this okay so
the result is the following if I
consider so for lambda bigger than this
constant I mentioned earlier for land a
bigger than lambda naught as n goes to
infinity the squared difference so if I
look at the expected squared difference
between this X hat constructed here and
the true Bayes estimator X hat base for
being is norm squared this in fact does
not go to 0 so I don't get an accurate
approximation of because the true of
agent Claudie I'm interested in and as a
consequence if I were to look at the
Bayes risk of this estimator X hat - the
truth xx transpose for being a so M
Squared this also does not go to the
optimal Bayes risk which I called silent
no sorry 1 on N squared both of these
words
okay so what we study instead in our
paper is is a different approach to
variation of inference it's called tap
variational inference and intact
variational Memphis what we consider
instead is a different energy functional
so consider instead M hat which
minimizes what I'll call the tap free
energy aardman / m / - 1 1 to the N
of denote this by F tap of M F tap of M
will be the mean field free energy F
mean field of M plus a certain
correction term and the correction term
is lambda squared over 4 1 minus Q of M
quantity squared where here Q of M is
the mean of the squared entry of them so
I'm going to consider this alternative
minimization problem and again if M hat
is a minimum of this then it has to
satisfy the first-order stationarity
condition for any fix no for any fixed
lambda bigger than lambda 0 I don't have
a quantitative that's right yeah we
still have this point okay so if M hat
were to minimize this tap free energy is
also yeah yeah there's some there's some
intuition for this which is that in this
model the posterior distribution the
coordinates are approximately
independent in some sense is it they're
independent the sense that if I look at
a finite dimensional marginal of the
posterior distribution then as n goes to
infinity those in that margin oh they're
actually in the book I take their back
there's a sign symmetry in the specific
model I wrote down but up to a global
plus minus 1 sign you have a certain
amount of independence that you expect
at the posterior which is why we might
believe this kind of approximation to be
true but what I'll try to show you is
that it's not true in the sort of joint
sense it's not sure that if I look at
the joint distribution of all n
variables in the posterior I have enough
independence and sort of that's where
this half correction
true that yeah the lambda in the loss
function is true lambda we're gonna
assume that lambda is known if you don't
know land but you can just ask to me
lambda from the largest eigen value what
is timestamp or that's a yoke I was
gonna write that down okay so a tap
right so if M hats optimizes this then
it satisfies the first-order condition
that the gradient of f tap at M hat has
to be equal to zero or at M has to be
equal to zero and if you write out what
is the stationarity condition here you
get the equation M is equal to the
hyperbolic tangent of lambda x ym minus
two minus lambda squared 1 minus Q of M
times M okay so this equation here first
appeared in the statistical physics
literature in the study of what's called
the Sherrington Kirkpatrick model for
for spin glasses and the this equation
appeared in a paper by Dallas Anderson
the cameras not gonna see what you're
about to write
that's okay it's okay all right
so tap-tap stands for Dallas Anderson
Palmer is a paper about the SK motto in
77 that first introduced that's sort of
okay so the theoretical result that we
have about this is that this somehow
fixes this problem of mean field base so
let M hats again let's say M hat is the
global minimizer so art being over m of
this tab free energy you should think of
it as a different criterion under which
your opto or under what you're trying to
estimate to this so you keep the
posterior to the products
yeah I'm still gonna make a product
approximation to the posterior but are
you know that's right it's not a KL
divergence I don't know if it comes
medulla it still depends enough at the
minimizer should still be the PM areas
okay so what was I gonna say okay okay
so so let me consider the global
minimizer of this functional M hat and
let me define the estimate of the signal
matrix X hat the vm hat M hat transpose
then we have the following result for
Lando's bigger than lambda naught as n
goes to infinity we get the correct
behavior so if I look at the expected
squared difference between X hat and the
true based solution X hat base that this
does go to 0 as n goes to infinity and
as a result if I look at the Bayes error
the Bayes risk achieved by this
estimator so minus the truth this does
go to this optimal risk okay that's fine
and then if you look at this sort of if
you look at the form of this function I
wrote down it's not a convex
optimization problem so a priori it
might not be clear as to whether we can
actually efficiently compute this
estimator in practice we don't give a
definitive answer to this but we give a
pretty strong evidence in favor of the
fact that this is computable we believe
it should be easy so the specific result
that we show in our work is that
furthermore this statement that I wrote
here is going to hold not just for the
global minimizer but this holds for any
critical point so any M hat satisfying
that the gradient is equal to 0 provided
that the value of this function is
sufficiently small so and that the value
of this top energy at M hat is less than
a certain constant which is we give a
bound of negative lambda square so this
bound you can check that if lambda is
big enough and you do some kind of a
spectral initialization you're gonna
fall in a region of the energy that's
less than this and what this suggests is
that if you run a gradient descent from
there it should probably cover
although we don't do it in actual
numerical analysis of the conversions
this is great in Europe this is the
gradient equal zero thank you
I Helia London zero should be a lot and
you uh I mean we want to get some kind
of recovery whenever lambdas bigger than
one I don't know whether I don't I don't
know whether this picture of the
let me just mention that so we're not
that we're not the first work that
considers this equation star to do
inference in this Bayesian setting if
you view this equation that I've marked
over there the top equation star as a
sort of fixed point equation where you
update M iteratively that's what's
called an approximate message passing
algorithm so so there's a connection
between star and the existing literature
of ANP algorithms and some of the early
rigorous work in this area was done by
both thousand fourteen and the specific
model was studied also by this bondage
yes but the flavor of there's a result
that we prove is a little bit different
I think we're the first people to
actually analyze the actual critical
points are the actual stationary points
of this iterative algorithm for finite n
what kind of you mean the fact that this
doesn't converge to zero let's say zero
you can know for finite any such yeah
you know so as an orient an asymptotic
regime where you're not going to be able
to get a consistent estimate because the
signal-to-noise is just about like if
lambda goes to infinity you're gonna be
able to get a consistent estimate and
you can study maybe rates of estimation
that we're studying a regime where the
best thing you can do is some constant
level of risk and asking the question
can we really achieve the constant level
of risk that the Bayes estimator should
be able to reach
anything to make more about the yeah
okay great thank you it's okay I'm gonna
let's see so what I wanted to do in this
talk was two things one is I wanted to
go through some kind of a dare fish or
some heuristic explanation of where this
tap correction comes from that's not
really a part of our work it's a very
classical statistical physics derivation
but maybe if we use go for the audience
to see and then I'll say a few things
about how we prove this result so maybe
that'll address your question right
okay so let me let me the first thing
that let me do is to kind of explain the
origin of this correction in the tap
free energy so it explained the origin
of this correction I'm going to start
with the posterior distribution PI of X
given Y and because I have a uniform
prior this is just proportional to the
likelihood of Y around the signal so
it's the perviness no difference in Y
minus lambda over half its transpose
squared and then you can check that
there's a constant here which is n over
if you expand the square and drop terms
that don't depend on X then this is
proportional to the exponential of
lambda over to X transpose Y X what I
want to do is to write this posterior
distribution by singling out a
particular coordinate of X so let me
write this as the prop of the
distribution over X I the ice coordinate
and then X super I wouldn't know if the
vector of n minus 1 other coordinates so
let me see you out this coordinate and
let me write to this this is posterior
density also by single I on a coordinate
so I can look at the part of this that
depends on I it's lambda times X I times
the sum J does not equal to I of Y IJ XJ
and then plus the rest of this stuff
that doesn't depend on X I so it's
lambda over 2 X super I and then what I
get is the minor of Y the N minus 1 by I
minus 1 minor of Y we were with the row
and column I removed a times X so I can
write the density and display and Chango
how this coordinate now what this shows
is that the dependence of X I and the
remaining coordinates in this model is
only through this term here this term
let me give it a name the traditional
name is H I it's called the cavity
filled and so what I can do is I can
write down what is the marginal law of X
I and H I gave it Y to get this marginal
law I need to sum over this the
remaining n minus 1 coordinates and so
what this looks like is the exponential
with lambda X IHI
and then time some distribution over a
chai that's induced by this part of the
person right so time is something all
that I'll call PI super I of a chai
given Y now what paisa per I is this is
the marginal law of a chai under the
distribution PI super I of X super I Y
super I which is proportional to X both
lambda over 2 X I transpose Y I X I so
what this distribution represents is
I've removed the ice coordinate from my
model right I'm looking at a model with
M minus 1 parameters this is the
corresponding posterior there and
whatever law that induces on X I
identified this variable H I and this is
my joint law of excitation
so we can let em most earier mean of X
and if I observe from this equation H is
given by Y times X minus some details on
the diagonal so we have h equals y times
X and if I look at the expectation of H
given Y this is going to be Y times M so
you can view both of these forms of
variational inference as making some
kind of an approximation to this
distribution on H I which is called a
cavity distribution so if I look at mean
field variational inference the kind of
approximation is making is just
replacing this by a constant right it's
going to ignore the fluctuations of this
variable H I and just make the
approximation that PI I of H I given Y
is approximately some Delta mass on a
coordinate view I make this kind of a
constant approximation then what I get
from here is that ym which is the
expectation of H given Y well H is just
a constant so this has to be mu
and what I get from this first equation
is that M is the expectation of x given
Y I think compute what is the
expectation of x given Y in this model
when H is equal to MU and I guess that
this is the hyperbolic tangent if I plug
in view from up here
I get the hyperbolic tangent of lambda
times ym and this is exactly the
equation so now the difference between
this and tap is that in the tap
approximation we're not going to ignore
the fluctuations of H I under this
cavity distribution instead we're going
to try to take that into account
but the way we'll take it into account
is that to will try to make an
approximation that the remaining
coordinates X J's are are approximately
independent under is heavy law PI and if
we believe this kind of approximation
then what this suggests is that H I
being the sum of these independent
random variables might have some kind of
a limiting galaxy and behavior for logic
so the approximation that we're going to
make for this distribution I of H I
given Y is that it's approximately
normal with some mean DUI and some
variance Sigma I squared
I'll enter this approximation our joint
law of X I and H I why this is will be
proportional to the exponential lambda x
IH I times the density of this normal
let me call that D nu I Sigma I squared
H I
and under this I can examine exactly
compute what are the marginal means of X
and H so I have that ym is equal to the
expectation of H given Y if I compute
this Gaussian integral I get an exact
form I getting u plus lambda Sigma
squared times the hyperbolic tangent of
lambda mu this equation is interpreted
entry Y so mu I plus lambda Sigma R
squared and I get X which is sorry I get
M which is the expectation of x given Y
I can also compute the mean of X under
this this approximation and what I get
is still a tan H lambda times du and if
I substitute mu from this first equation
down in the second one I get a tan H of
lambda Y M minus this correction term
here I get minus lambda squared Sigma
squared and then H of n reviewers just
so I get it I get a fixed point equation
of this form where what we've seen is
that if I try to account for the
variance of this variable H I then I
need to subtract a certain correction
term in the equation finally so why
should this correction term be what we
have that Sigma I square should
represent the variance under this cavity
field of H I'd given Y and if we believe
that these X J's are approximately
independent and what this should be is
just the sum J does not equal I Y IJ
squared times the variance under if you
have any field of the individual XJ
given Y the X J's here are plus minus 1
so this is 1 minus
vacation of XJ given y squared and we'll
make this approximation that's roughly 1
- MJ's or MJ is just the mean of X
and finally the last observation is that
this variance of XJ given why this is
really given why I the minor with row I
and column I removed it's independent of
the row of Y and so because of this
independence when we look at the Sun we
expect some kind of a law large numbers
phenomenon occasion where this is
approximately four large and the sum
over J the expectation of Y IJ squared
is roughly 1 over n times 1 minus MJ
squared and this is exactly this
quantity 1 minus Q so we get that the
variances for each coordinate is roughly
1 minus Q of M and once I plugged it
into here I get this time you view this
as a sort of correction that accounts
for the very end that the variation in
this cavity
so there many times that I have I so so
this is not really the approach that we
use to prove the result that we have but
I wanted to show where this comes from
and in the remaining ten minutes or so I
want to give an outline of what is the
strategy by which we proved our main is
so our results said it was a result of
the following form if I take any
critical point of this tap free energy
that's below a certain value of the
function then that should give me an
accurate approximation to the true based
posterior of this model right that was
the result this result for simplicity
let me just assume without loss of
generality that the true vector X is
just all ones this is just for
notational convenience and what will
define us for any probability
distribution the probability
distribution let me call it row on this
interval minus 1 to 1 I'm going to defy
for linear function was a row so I'll
define Q of Rho is the integral of x
squared 0 I'll define M of Rho which is
the integral of x 0 and define a of Rho
which is the integral of x times the
hyperbolic arc tangent of X 0 and we'll
define H of Rho which is the integral of
this binary entropy function H of X 0 I
can accumulate all 4 of these into a
single vector so let me define T of Rho
with a viq M a and H and you should
interpret this as a certain projection
of this measure Rho onto our for I've
been summarizing the distribution by
just four numbers for a vector so for a
vector M in RN we're going to identify
this with its empirical distribution of
its coordinates so identify em with what
I'll call Rho n which is the empirical
law of the coordinates or it's a 1 over
n sum over I of the Delta M s X I and
use the notation Q of M is the same
thing as Q of Rho n
so particular queue of n would be the
average squared entry of M which is what
I wrote down
so one one sort a trivial but important
observation is that if I were to look at
the risk that we're interested in or the
loss function so if we look at this
error one over N squared mmm transpose
minus xx transpose for being
historically this is the loss that I
defined this loss is actually just a
function of this projection of M right
so if I expand out this the square in
particular you can check that this is
one plus U of M squared minus two
to the question I put the road there is
a finding based on the deoxidize deer
racks at the mis thank you
and so our profess to step so the first
step what we study is the the expected
number of critical points that project
onto any particular set so let me set
what we call crit n of some set u and R
for to be the number of critical points
so the the set of critical points of
this type free energy so where the
gradient is equal to zero and that M
projects into this set now we're gonna
try to count this and so what we show in
the first step of our proof is that if I
look at the expectation of the number of
critical points that project on to you
this has an exponential upper bound this
is less than or equal to n times a
certain complexity function so n times
the supreme l'm over t and they said you
of some function as star of T and then
plus some little o of n correction term
for some star that maps are for tomorrow
probably you won't have you'll see if I
can give you a sense of what this
function looks like
okay our argument for this is using a
catch rice formula kind of argument this
was first done by Fiat araf and o4 and
made rigorous in a paper by Al finger
been a recent journey
you know should I take you a little bit
more detail about how this works but let
me first tell you what's the second step
of the proof so the sort of important
but trivial observation is that if this
if the supreme over T in this set you of
this complexity function we define is
actually negative then what this means
is that the expected number of critical
points is exponentially small and n
which just by Markov inequality means
that with very high probability I don't
have any critical points so if this
happens then the number of critical
points are projecting to this that U is
equal to zero with high probability the
second step of our proof is that we
analyze this complexity function and so
this is the part where we use lambda has
to be larger than a constant so for
lambda bigger than lambda naught there
exists some set u and R for it's
depending on lambda such that the
following properties hold so the first
is that with high probability if I have
a critical point so if the gradient of
this tough energy at m is equal to zero
and the value of the energy is less than
the threshold negative lambda squared
over three then this in fact implies
that this M has to project into my set
you event belongs to you the second
property we want to set u to satisfy is
the following that so okay so so the
second observation is that the global
minimizer let me call this M hat
of this type free energy does satisfy
this constraint with high probability so
has the value of the energy at this
global minimizer is really less than
negative lambda squared over three with
high probability and then we do an
analysis of this complexity functional
on this set u that we defined the third
property is that there exists a special
point T star I can call this Q star by
star a star
each star this is an hour for where the
complexity at this point t star is OS of
T star is actually just equal to zero
and if M were to project exactly on to
this point T star then we achieve the
optimal Bayes error so and this quantity
that I wrote up here 1 plus Q star
squared minus 2 m star squared is
actually exactly equal to this optimal
phase risk lambda
and finally we have this qualitative
statement that for any epsilon greater
than zero if I look at what is the
maximum value of this complexity
function s of T so super team super s of
T where T does belong to you but T is
not close to T star or minus T star so
the distance from TV to TV star
it's bigger than epsilon by a science
symmetry I need also restrict you to
minus T star is bigger than that's a lot
that this is actually negative is s
related to s star yes his SS is just a
start
okay so what what these together means
is the following area so the picture
that this paints is the follow I want to
look at critical points of my tap free
energy where the energy value is less
than this threshold and what we show is
that so first of all the global
minimizer does satisfy this so there's
at least one such point any such point
has to project into this this set u and
R for where we can use step one of our
proof to understand that basically
everywhere in this set there's
probability zero of having a critical
point there except for in an arbitrarily
small neighborhood of some special point
key star and actually minus T star as
well so there's this T star this also
holds for minus T's so these these two
special points which are really the
global minimizer's of my function or
they project there and so for an
arbitrarily small neighborhood we can
show that as n goes to infinity any
critical point which satisfies this
condition that must fall into this
arbitrarily small neighborhood of T star
minus sister okay do something to show
what it so many close ones like why do
we have for example possibly an
exponentially large number of critical
points QM is a single race
much opinion I mean I think it's known
for these kinds of operas that our
sample was such and and and and and is
okay I don't I don't know I don't have
much intuition but I think that so at
low energy levels they don't have
actually so the belief is that there's
only this one this one critical for high
enough energy levels their complexity
function here yeah
what do you mean by both complexity of
the company so many yeah that basically
is the critical points are you have the
term out there right - yeah so this is
just this is just if if I were to have
some point M you know the the risk the
loss that's achieved by this this
estimator defined by M is is this
particular function of M and what we're
showing is that you know there's a
particular point to where this loss is
exactly the Bayes risk in a neighborhood
of this point is sort of where we expect
all of the critical points beyond a
certain energy level and so they're all
good enough to achieve the optimal
phasers and outside of this neighborhood
at least up to this this larger set you
there are no more critical
zero minutes all right I'll stop so you
can't you can't change the prior the tap
free energy would be different to
actually think that's work I mean
because you're familiar with these so
we're talking four in a Bayesian
inference setting so it is replica
symmetric yeah it's yeah it's because of
that that we believe the global
minimizer of the tap free energy should
correspond to
not just for this prior before other
parts but the specific form of what the
correction in the tap energy should look
like you would have to work out
some variation of interest with some
family of possible distribution is other
than they go you repeat the question
yeah what was the question was is this
method equivalent to some other form of
variational inference with some other
family of distributions other than me
nephew let me rephrase your question as
maybe is this equivalent to making an
approximation to the posterior that's
not a product law is that what you're
asking
no I don't think so because at the end
of the day this is still you know the
approximation we're making is still some
kind of a product approximation the
product approximation is correct at the
level of low dimensional marginals very
calm for your questions you can you can
imagine that prior and posterior that
gives you the correct answer you care
about the karcher time in a very
intuitive way but you can't just calm
about it by imposing it on the prior is
that the question so possible right in
pencil as possible and you get the
correction term another price another
posterior I don't know what it means to
get it from the prior I mean once you
have the prior yes well the posterior is
gonna come from the prior I didn't the
posterior is just gonna come from this
prior whatever that gives me a sum
posterior I can write down the KL
divergence where that posterior and then
we add a correction term on top of that
ki so it is still a product
approximation in itself because of the
you know we're trying to we're trying to
compute the expectation of a second
moment of X so this is really the
product you know it's a property of
dokdo two-dimensional marginal
distributions of this mass which are
which are correctly you know roughly in
so that's still in some sense the right
approximation of going to make up these
for modeling this but because of the
fact that we're estimating a high
dimensional parameter vector there's
some kind of a global interaction
between these variables that we want to
account for when I write a joke
suppose you made a different
approximation of the posterior say like
that it's a tree structure a posterior
or some kind of combination of trees or
something else that you know we often
think of being able to do efficient
inference in it is this are we still
gonna have substantial problems is it
possible this fixes some of these issues
you can change the model right so for
example if I were to consider instead of
this Gaussian noise which kind of field
approximation we made whatever what your
tree structure come from I mean our
priors is independent well the posterior
is not the host air is not in Paris so
you would get some kind of a tree
structure in the posterior I think if
your likelihood like you do it your
instead of having your posterior view
yeah so look okay so that was your with
you know some kind of work the
approximation or tree approximation or I
don't know some alternative
approximation to mean feel we can talk
about this stuff why I mean I think I
think you'll get a tree oh go get a tree
structure and posterior if like your
your likelihood of variables x have some
kind of a sparse interactions dr.
Cooper's to have a no problem
you made a new field approximate yes
that a mean field make a different
approximation it's the same question
that they asked that yeah but it's still
it's still bigger than just the
problematic now I don't want to record
tap on its do something totally
different
I don't know
okay well we now have a break until I
don't know once until we bring the power